benvenuti in un nuovissimo a grande
richiesta oggi si parla di ragazze
gelose
se almeno una volta nella vita avete
detto una di queste frasi che vi sto per
elencare mi dispiace per voi ma siete
catalogate come ragazze gelose quindi
segnatevi bene tutte le frasi di questo
video che avete già detto almeno una
volta nella vita e alla fine del video
se vi renderete conto che mi avete dette
tutte vincerete la fascia come ragazza
gelosa dell'anno partiamo subito perché
non mettere la mano quando siamo in giro
ti prepari di me
ammettilo che non ti vuoi far vedere
insieme avere neanche una foto insieme a
me schifo c'è questo il profilo di un
singolo non ti vergogni
perché ci così spesso ultimamente è da
quando le tue amiche ti chiamano vedi
solo io posso darti media capito no ma
guardate in un'altra volta il culo ma
poi qualcuno si fa si singola vai
tranquillo ma non la scusa perché messa
laica questa tipa io lo capisco perché
tu debba uscire da solo perché lo posso
venire anch'io bello non mi interessa se
tua zia comunque la femmina non mi
risponde non visualizza come lo sento mi
ha tradito perché li riguardano il
telefono
chi è che ti fa ridere scusa a e tua
cugina sì sì certo tua cugina perché non
l'ho mai vista e non è che se mi vedi
col tuo telefono in mano dire che però
stavo controllando è no ma da quando
tiri così per uscire perché ti ha
salutato quella la conosce
ma se in giro conto mamma aspetta un
attimo
salve signor a tutto bene lei è perché
ti ha salutato se non la conosci è tutto
suo profumo dovevi andare allora non sa
io sono comprensiva e che ti dica ciò
come va ci può anche stare ma
abbracciarci abbracciarti e veramente un
affronto abbracciati norma cioè io ho
solo foto con te e tu tu quante ne hai
neanche una neanche una non ho tempo
riuscire benissimo con i tuoi amici ci
mancherebbe però che c'è anche sono una
ragazza devo venire anch'io finalmente
perché non rispondere al telefono doveri
è questo nascondere perché non
rispondevi il pensiero in stavo male per
3 a rispondere davanti a me sono
nell'inter nascondere mai ma quante
cugini dopo una visione sono saltate voi
40 cugini ma per scherzando perché canti
come tutta la felicità ha fatto qualcosa
sicuro ma c'è qualche ragazza ascolta io
sento voci di ragazze e sci nomi e
shinobi no allora fortuna ci siamo
capiti
rispondi le davanti a me ora perché non
mi rispondevi amo guarda le storie di
questa tipa e fammi sapere se nel locale
dove andato lui adesso mi spieghi cosa
dovevi fare di così importante da non
rispondermi no scusa e tu come fai a
saperlo che la tua ex si è lasciata non
capisco perché la tua vita ti mette
laica ogni foto tranne a quelle dove ci
sono anch'io
adesso vado a farmi un bel giretto sotto
instagram no non le foto direct idirect
quelli che contano
dammi la password non so da chi è
simonetta lo cascio che vive a napoli a
un amico in comune con me tu non mi
prendere in giro tu non sei a casa
ammettilo ammettilo che senza
controllarne il profilo che schifo
allora visto che sei a casa adesso mi
mandi una bella foto è il camera tua con
i giornali di oggi
no non sono gelosa ma che ti permette di
rivolgerti a però l'altra moto in
attacco la testa o se preferisci
facciamo un bel facetime
sai che cosa mi rappresenta casi è
attivo su instagram e non visualizzi
miei messaggi ma neanche io la conosco
proli ha messo live di amore ma che ha
bisogno di avere delle amiche sono io la
tua amica ma come mi era mica sono nato
maniera mica son la sua confidente sono
tua mamma auto cugina sono tutto io come
bisogno di nessun altro
allora spiegami perché non mi hai mai
presentato una tua amica ma su facebook
lei più di 400 allora rispondi prima che
faccia scoppia un casino con chi sei
beh se le metti mi piace vuol dire che
ti piace ma non sono gelosa di sto
facendo vere domande ti piace sì o no
certo è veramente guardato culo sei un
porco guarda
amore mi dici la verità non mi arrabbio
ti piacciono
non c'è niente da fare siete tutti
uguali mi fate schifo
che delusione è finita questa volta per
sempre te lo giuro non mi cerca adesso
voglio sapere quante fasce di ragazza
gelosa dell'anno devo consegnare dopo
questo video mi raccomando aspetto qui
sotto nei commenti l'elenco delle vostre
frasi se la prima volta che vedete un
mio video e non vi siete ancora iscritti
al canale ricordatevi di iscrivervi
subito e attivare la campanella che
trovate vicino al tasso di iscrizione
per ricevere sempre le notifiche ogni
volta di carico un video e soprattutto
per essere i primi a commentare
ricordatevi seguirmi su tutti gli altri
social facebook instagram è in musica
io vi mando un bacione e ci vediamo al
prossimo video ad ora ciao